ATTENTION: ALL NINE-YEAR OLD GAMERS
*CLAP* *CLAP*
PEWDIEPIE IS IN GREAT DANGER
HE NEEDS YOUR HELP
TO WIPE OUT T-SERIES
from "Youtube" once and for all
We must not let T-Series reach 69 million subscribers before he does
Now to help him,
All Pewdiepie needs is for you to subscribe to his channel!
preetty eassyy
SO BE SURE TO *HIT* THAT BELL!! *already did*
*SMACKS* AND TURN THOSE NOTIFICATIONS ON
Ssspread the news with all your friends *fellow 9-year old*
throughout the WORLD
But you gotta be quick so that Pewdiepie
can achieve the EPIC VICTORY ROYALLEE
and prevail forever with zero deaths!
And also
be sure to subscribe
to grandday
*CLAP* *Pewds Goes Super Syan*
*CLAP* *Alexa, Play Meme Review*
MEME REVIEW
*CLAP*
OH YEAAA (it's No Nut November buddy)
This is the last.
Guys this could be the last
MEME REVIEW?!? *noooo*
as the best YouTuber in the world
That's right. That's how that works.
Please guys.
ATTENTION ALL GAMERS *and 9 year olds*
I need your help. This is serious.
*Meme review clap*
*oof Soundtrack *
I'm gonna have to use everything in my power at this point.
*continues sad music*
But let's get into the memes.
EVERYONE WE HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE!
*CLAP* *CLAP* MEME REVIEW!
*pewds laugh* EVERYONE, WE HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE!
SO CUTE!!
*CLAP* *CLAP* *MEME REVIEW*
Absolute mad lads
What a bunch of legends.
I'm proud of you.
These kids can clearly say, they are doing their part.
Now can you say you are doing yours?
WAIT A MINUTE! *hold up your horses*
*pewds processing what he saw*
Go back on the footage.
*configuration in process*
*analyzing data*
*disappointed*
Is that a gnome? Is that a GNOME?!
Uh..Guys. *breathes heavily*
I hate to say this, but *continues heavy breathing*
I think there's a gnome right there!
*sigh poor brad 1# and 2. good luck with him*
Guys, it's not a joke. There's a gnome right there!
*CLAP*
*Drunk Gnome appears*
I thought we had a deal, kids. Huh?!
I thought we had a- *pewds trying to speak English* whatever
I'm gonna find you all, okay?
I don't care what it takes. No one gnomes me. Okay?
*TRAnsITITION!
How's it going everyone?
Poppy Harlow here for a SPECIAL PEW NEWS NEW SEG-!
Elon Musk just tweeted: "Send me ur dankest memes!!"
Wow. *thanks Brad1*
That is
EPIC
Elon Musk billionaire, okay?! *Elon senpai*
is slowly, but surely tapping into the meme industry
There's potential rumors about him
funding catgirls *meow*
'cause it's genetically possible
BUT THEY "LaCk FunDINg"
Maybe that's a new business he's looking into? (Thank You Elon Musk)
A lot of people seem confused why Elon is tapping into memes (wanna be pewds)
But surely, it can only mean
that there's a lot of money for the people in the industry.
So this is great news for everyone.
How did they know?
"Horoscope: You're probably breathing right now"
"People: Surprised pikachu face"
How much could this meme be worth at this point?
Incredible.
Elon Musk: "twitter meme"
"Twitter users:" *pewds laugh*
I think what we're all wondering here is..
When is Elon Musk creating his meme account?
Elon Musk had a meme account already.
Why does Tesla's logo look so much like T-Series?
Okay guys. I'm tired of pretending I'm okay with this.
T-Series taking over my channel
and now Elon trying to take over memes.
And their logo types look very similar.
Guys *intense conspiracy theory*
*sad music* I'm scared.
For the first time, I'm not making any jokes.
I'm 100%... Terrified.
I know this is it.
It's over for me.
*ominous sound* This is it. YouTube finally got
what they wanted.
Just don't forget me when I'm gone. That's all I ask.
That's all I ask.
*Clap**Clap
*Cool Music*
OH LOOK
Oh Look at here you have been visited by the Ben Shapiro Hamburger Helper Glove
You will now be OWNED with LOGIC
AND FAX (it's FACTS) unless you can say *uhh* "Okay, this is epic" in the comments
Hurry up and say it down in the comments.
I don't need to write that down, I'll remember it
also me: *forgets it*
*clap* *clap*
I do that too!
That's literally me!
*claps* Me: Installs 500 Skyrim mods
Skyrim: Crashes immediately (so sad)
AH!
THIS IS ME! (honest guy)
I'll save later!
gameboy: *battery dies, loses 4 hours of progress*
Me:
This is literally me!
As a 9-year-old kid, this is me as you (mindblownn)
The Tiktok pikachu meme
gets a..
2 (rates LIKE A BOSS)
This is a Spongebob tear meme
Okay?
See now, I'm getting angry
The Swedishness disappears
*laughs
THOSE GODDAMN SPONGEBOB MEMES
They're everywhere. This is a Spongebob Tear meme
I'm sorry, Elon.
You can do better. I know you can (aw <3)
But, okay, you know, he's new in the business
So I'll give it a pass
*pewds singing* Hit or miss. I guess they never miss. HUH.
*pewds singing even more*
He goes *Pewds tries to speak English*
Hit the dab... uh...
And he will MISS YA.
*random buffering* WIZ KHALIFA.
*Sed reacc music plays*
These tic toc videos...
Is not just causing the internet great months of pain
Great months of cancer
*June 21-July 22*
It's also tearing the internet apart.
The internet has declared that this is the new Queen
*Indian Drama Music 101 plays*
*Pewds nods* Of the Uganda Knuckles,
b a s i c a l l y.
All you needed is a girl dressing up with anime cosplay
Singing a song about Mia Khalifa diss track
And that's all it takes to blow up on the internet these days.
*disappointed sarcastic pewds*
Congratulations, everyone.
Now on the other hand,
you have this God-forbidden
i love his sweater paws
*claps* If that was not epic, I don't know what to say.
(uwu someone tell me he doesnt look sups cute)
Thank you BEN SHAPIRO
VERY COOL
Thanks- Thank you guys for watching meme review! <3
If you want anyone else to host bonus meme,
lemme know
'Cause the less work for me the better honestly
(SUBSCRIBE!! yay)
Thanks to Ben Shapiro again as well
And, that's it for me for now, remember to..
goodbye
THAT, are addictive, stimulative
and could have no side effects other than (?)
They do not care about your feelings.
[SUB TO XOS (Team Slinger)]
next meme *claps*
STAY AMAZING AND POSITIVE YOU LOVELY PEOPLE!! (SUBSCRIBE TO KEVIN SATRON FOR EDITING SOMEONE'S SUBTITLE, LOL)